foreign
it's definitely been a rocky ride we've
seen so many ups and downs since the
pandemic the rise in crime
and the houseless and homeless
population
that continues to be a challenge that I
think the city is starting to get their
arms wrapped around so that's very
encouraging safety is a priority for
everyone and I think a lot of
the surrounding areas the residents that
live in the surrounding areas to
downtown still feel unsafe to come
downtown
you know certainly a different climate
than you know two years ago when we were
experiencing doing business during
pandemic and riots and everything else
that was going on there are no more
riots
um
but people still feel unsafe because
there's been a narrative that's been set
and I think as small business owners we
are going above and beyond running our
own businesses to come together as a
community create wonderful experience
encourage people to come back to
downtown and to feel safe but I think
the city needs to partner with us to do
that to ensure that it's not just a
one-sided effort
I think there's a lot more the city can
do the professional criminals that are
out there busting into businesses and
wreaking havoc truly we need to catch
those folks and we do need to prosecute
those folks I recognize there's a lot of
complications around our D.A but but
really not having enough public
defenders to defend these criminals but
when somebody has been recorded on
camera well over a dozen times backing
their vehicle into a business I think
it's time we do something about that I
want to be really clear there are
opportunist criminals that are out there
people that should not be confused with
our houseless population that are live
that are dealing with a lot of other
concerns drug addiction mental health
needs that people that really need
Services we'd like to see our police
work in concert with the DA's office and
work together and we'd like to see
police showing up in a timely manner to
these calls and these break-ins we'd
like to see a greater police presence I
think a greater presence of security
detail and not necessarily police
because they certainly have their hands
full and have serious crimes to deal
with but I remember when I moved here
from Los Angeles many years ago I was
always impressed that every once in a
while you would see an officer on on
horseback riding through the city and I
haven't seen that in some years and I
remember my kids really like being
amazed and thinking that was great so
something light-hearted like that I know
we have some bike Patrol now so more of
that where it's more friendly a friendly
presence but nevertheless a presence
that says there's safety there's
security if something should go awry but
I keep hearing we don't have enough
police out on the street if that truly
is the case then we need to enlist
others and we have Portland Bureau of
Transportation
let's get let's get them out there with
big lights on the sides of their
vehicles and let's get them driving
around we made a recommendation well
over a year ago that we have patrols
that are out shining shining lights on
buildings
a lot of it is just preventative you
know just keeping the eyes on these
businesses and keeping them from getting
repeatedly broken into